JAMES HAWKINS: My name
is James Hawkins.
I'm the tech lead of the Chrome
team in Los Angeles.
And for the past year, we've
been working very closely with
the Google+ Photos team on a new
product that's the Google+
Photos Chrome app.
So this is a Chrome
packaged app.
And if you'll remember, packaged
apps were announced a
little over a year ago.
And this is the key piece of
Chrome's app platform.
Packaged apps give you the
ability to have extended
permissions, you can do
a little bit more.
You can have a more native look
and feel with your app.
It's a step above what
you can do with the
web platform today.
So we're going to talk about
Google+ Photos Chrome app.
Actually, instead of
talking about it,
let's cut to the demo.
So this is Google+ Photos,
the Chrome app.
This is my personal account.
I've got all my photos
loaded up into it.
We're doing some
nice scrolling.
And if you note, I'm on
a Pixel right here.
So we obviously have touchscreen
capabilities to do
scrolling with this.
OK, so we're viewing
some photos.
Let's say I want to go in and
check out a particular photo.
All right, I've got this photo,
and I've got my nice
information, my tags,
and details.
Very neat.
But I just went and used my
camera and took a bunch of
pictures, and I've got
it on an SD card.
I'd like to upload these
to the Cloud.
I want to share with
my friends.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Close this.
So here we go.
The app was already open.
And it's already started
importing photos, and it's
going to start uploading them.
We can view the ones that
are on this SD card.
Cool.
So these are the pictures
that I just took.
Got a little notification that
we had some photos copied, and
they're being uploaded
right now.
We got a notification that we're
finding the best photos,
and there we go.
What you just saw is something
that you heard
about in the keynote.
This is autocuration.
So in the back end, Google said,
we're looking at your
photos, we want to see what
are the best photos of the
ones you just took.
Let's make it very simple for
you to share the best photos
that you have with your
friends, your
families, et cetera.
For example, this photo
has been deemed to be
underexposed.
Cool.
All right.
That's fine.
I'm not too picky.
I just want the best
photos to go up.
So we want to share these.
Cool.
I've shared it with my family.
Cool new photos.
And so these are the photos
that I just shared.
We can change the name.
No, it's '13.
It is early after all.
Cool.
So this is Google+ Photos.
You've got the autocuration
magic behind the scenes.
You've got a very
slick interface.
Very fast viewing of
all your photos,
just really nice scrolling.
And we're going to talk a bit
today about what it took to
develop this product
as a Chrome
packaged app on the platform.
AUDIENCE: Is it available
in the marketplace?
JAMES HAWKINS: This is
not available yet.
It'll be available soon.
So we started developing
this product with a
set of goals in mind.
What did we want
to accomplish?
When we started development, the
only way to view photos in
Chrome OS was through the file
manager, and even then, that
was not the best experience.
You could do some
minimal editing.
You couldn't really
share very easily.
And the viewing experience
was just a stopgap.
That's not to say,
it's not good.
But we wanted to do
something better.
We wanted a better photos
experience for ChromeOS.
In addition, we wanted a place
where the Google+ Photos team
could experiment with new UI,
new back end functionality
like we're talking about
with autocuration.
In fact, autocuration was not
available to the public in the
Google+ desktop until we just
announced it at I/O
a couple days ago.
And so this product was the
only place where the
autocuration team could see
autocuration live, see how it
worked out, get a lot of
feedback on the feature.
And so this is going to continue
to be one of the
places where that feature
development happens like
sandboxed, if you will.
And coming from the Chrome team
side of things, we wanted
to make sure that the platform
had everything that we needed
in order to be very successful
and very easy for people to
develop apps.
What's missing?
Could we identify it?
What are the bugs?
It's a very nascent platform,
and a lot of the API's that
are being developed are even,
right now, in development.
And we wanted to test them
out, have a user for the
platform instead of giving it to
you guys, and you guys have
to cut your teeth on it.
Which is not the best
experience.
We wanted to do that ourselves
to spare you guys some pain.
And as a part of that, as well,
we are Chrome developers
in addition to doing some
of this front end stuff.
So when we did find areas that
were lacking in the platform,
we could go in and add those
APIs that we were missing.
And I'll talk about one of those
specifically later on.
So Chrome, as you know, has
three core principles.
You want your UI
to be extremely
quick, extremely fast.
You want animations to be
very snappy and fluid.
When you have jink, you have
stuttering, you have a really
bad user experience.
It's jarring for the user.
Keeping your app very simple,
to me, it means
getting out of the way.
Get your UI out of the way of
the user, out of the way of
what they're trying to do.
And sometimes that is actually
the hardest thing to
accomplish.
Security, obviously, is
extremely important.
You want to keep your users
secure not only from your app
misbehaving but from malicious
attackers that can use your
app to harm your user.
You want to make sure that
that is not possible.
So we took these principles to
mind when we were developing
in the app.
And the challenges that we faced
when developing the app
I'm going to frame around
these core principles.
Speed.
You've got to be fast.
Everybody wants to be fast.
One of the first problems we
ran into was with having to
have a client side photo and
needing to know if we needed
to upload it or not.
You obviously don't want to
waste bandwidth if the user
already has that photo
in the Cloud.
And so the way we did that is
to store SHA-512 hashes of
these photos in the Cloud when
it was already uploaded.
And so when we have a new photo
to upload, we have to
calculate that hash to
say hey, do you have
this photo or not?
And if not, we don't
need to upload it.
So we have a little demo here.
This is a quite large image.
It's about 12 megabytes,
I think.
And this is just one example
of what the user could be
uploading that we need
to get the hash of.
And we found that the JavaScript
implementation,
while we could optimize it as
much as we possibly could, it
could never compare to a
native implementation.
And we got that native
implementation through Native
Client, which allows
you to run C++
binaries in your web app.
It's a really amazing technology
that is extremely
useful, especially for these use
cases where you need to do
data processing, you want to get
bare bones as close to the
metal as possible.
So I'm going to do
a little demo.
We have hashing done
in JavaScript.
And we have hashing done
in Native Client.
And we're going to get
the timings of those.
And we'll see what the
difference is.
OK.
Almost three seconds compared
to 200 milliseconds.
That is an order of magnitude
difference.
That's amazing.
Not to mention the fact that
Native Client doesn't block
the UI, the main thread.
Whereas this JavaScript
implementation does.
So if you're taking three
seconds to hash an image, your
user is doing nothing.
They're looking at your app
not doing anything.
So Native Client saved
us on this one.
And, in fact, with more
native-like apps being
produced for the web, I think
we're going to see Native
Client being used a
tremendous amount.
One of the first big apps that
was done with Native Client
was actually games.
That makes perfect sense.
You've got to have high, super
high performance calculating
with a lot of data.
So actually, I want to go in,
and let's look at this and see
how we hooked up with
Native Client.
So we're going to go into
the JavaScript.
And the meat of this is the
NaCl hash for the NaCl
implementation.
We'll ignore the JavaScript
for now.
We're going to do document,
the element ID file_io.
I/O. So let's go see
what that was.
That is, I'm going to
zoom this up so you
guys can see it.
That's an embed of
type X NaCl.
This file_io.nmf is an
NaCl manifest format.
And it specifies what
the binary is for--
I'm not going to open it up.
But it specifies what
the binary is
that needs to be run.
We communicate with this
with postMessage.
So we postMessage the file
name, and inside the
implementation of the NaCl
module, we take that file
name, do the hashing on it in
C++, that's compiled, and send
a message back through the
NaCl API to the app.
And we handle that
message here.
So this is essentially
how we were doing
it in Native Client.
It's actually really simple.
So this is what, maybe 10
lines total of code for
handling this.
And C++ code on the
other side.
The meat of it is getting the
NaCl module built, which there
are tons of tutorials
out there.
It's not that hard.
Doesn't want to full screen.
OK, hold on.
Just one second.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you very much.
I was zoomed in.
So the next issue that we
are running into is
the data store layer.
So with Photos, there
are users that
have, say, 40,000 photos.
This is a case that
we have to handle.
It's very difficult.
And the fact that this app needs
to be native, needs to
act like a real app on your
platform, you have to have
offline support, which means you
need to store your users'
data locally to some degree.
You don't have to store
everything but
at least the metadata.
For Photos, you would have maybe
a link to where the file
is on the file system and the
dimensions of the photo and
any other metadata
that you have.
This needs to be stored
somewhere in your data layer,
and we use IndexedDB do this.
The problem that we ran
into with our initial
implementation is that we were
not using transactions in
IndexedDB appropriately.
And this was kind of killer
because it's not immediately
obvious what you're doing wrong
when your reads are
going really slowly
unless you're very
familiar with the API.
So I'll give you a demo here.
We have writing 1,000 records,
reading, removing them, et
cetera, and with transaction
and with no transaction.
We'll see what the
differences are.
OK, it's taking a long time.
And this is even worse.
This is two orders of magnitude
worse without
transactions.
And it's very simple.
Let's go in and see what
the transactions do.
So you open a transaction,
we'll zoom this up.
And I thank you very much.
I will zoom back out when
I'm done with this.
So we have a notification when
the transaction is complete.
That is when we say I've done
all of my 1,000 operations.
And you just do all of your
operations at once using the
transaction object.
You get the object store out
from the transaction.
You do your operation
on the store.
And once this goes
out of scope, the
transaction will be complete.
And we'll be done.
The implementation that doesn't
use transaction has
one database transaction
per call.
So every time you are doing a
new call, you're creating a
new transaction.
Very inefficient.
So I think the biggest part
of making this app very
performant is the scrolling
performance.
And this was the biggest
challenge for us to solve.
There's a lot of optimizations
you have to do
all across the board.
You have to make sure that
you don't have any leaks.
you're doing the right thing
in order to be on fast
scroll path.
This needs to be very
non-choppy.
Otherwise, if it is choppy,
your users are jarred.
And they're just
very confused.
It looks like not
a native app.
It looks like a web app.
And so the solution for this
is a fast scroll path.
The fast scroll path is
where the GPU does the
scrolling for you.
Offload the processing for
handling this chunk of video
memory, you've got everything
rendered into it, and whenever
you scroll, you just ask the
GPU to do the [? offset ?]
for you.
This is common in games,
graphics, whatever.
And we're starting to
add this to the
browser in a lot of places.
Keep in mind that this is very
preliminary, and the GPU team
is working very hard on this.
But there are a lot of things
you have to keep in mind.
When you do scrolling, the
element that you scroll has to
be the body element.
That's the first thing.
And I say that right off the bat
because it's not obvious
that is a requirement
or a constraint.
And you can set up your DOM,
your HTML structure, in such a
way that it's very hard
after the fact to move
scrolling to the body.
And we ran into that problem.
It was a total pain.
For example, let's go look
at the app for a second.
We have our main content
here in the middle.
And I'm going to go into
the single photo
view to show you more.
In the toolbar on the top and
this sidebar on the right, the
toolbar and the sidebar were
siblings of the main content.
And this was all in one wrapper
that could be scrolled.
This doesn't work because
you're not on the body.
And in order to be on the body
element, we had to make the
toolbar and the sidebar
fixed position.
And that has its own
intricacies.
Like for example, the scroll
bar goes all way the up
through the toolbar.
There's really not anything we
can do about that right now.
And if that's the worst of our
problems that gets us this
type of scrolling, this fast
scrolling, then it's
definitely worth it.
You also want to make sure
when you're handling the
scroll event, that you're
not doing too much work.
This is when the browser is
saying I'm about to scroll,
I'm about to change
your UI, the page.
If you start doing a lot of
processing, maybe start
loading a bunch of image
elements, a lot of photo
elements, that inherently is
going to make the scrolling a
lot worse, a lot slower.
So you want to offload your
processing to a time that is
not in your body scrolling.
Perhaps queueing up and batching
operations that could
be done later.
And we'll talk about that
in one of our solutions.
One thing that we had to do
was to reduce image loads.
So when you set the source
attribute on an image element,
the browser, no matter whether
it's in the view port or not,
the image element has
to decode the image.
And we found that the decoding
can be very expensive, and it
obviously scales with the
size of the image.
So you want to question
expensive
operations like that.
And setting image source is
one of those expensive
operations.
So we talked about batching your
heavy processing so that
you're not doing everything
in your scroll.
One way to do this, and the best
way right now, is to have
a callback to this method call
RequestAnimationFrame.
This method is a way for the
browser to alert you, hey, I'm
about to do an animation, and
you should do some heavy
processing in this time period,
batch it all up.
Do everything at once because
we're going to
swap everything out.
And this is a way for the
browser to say this will be
less janky.
And so whenever we do
scrolling, we do
RequestAnimationFrame, and then
we obviously need to load
more elements.
So when we
RequestAnimationFrame, the
callback, we do that
image loading then.
Because that's when the browser
says, do your heavy,
intensive processing.
And this is really great
to have high
performance in your scrolling.
Another thing that I think is
starting to be more well
known, but it is not that well
known I think, and it's not
very necessarily intuitive, is
that when you measure certain
properties on DOM elements, you
can cause reflows, which
may cause repaints.
And painting is the one
thing you want to
minimize at all costs.
If you're doing a bunch of
paints, then you don't have
the benefit of the GPU doing
the scroll for you.
Because you're just thrashing
what the GPU had.
ScrollTop, for example.
If you're reading scrollTop, not
writing to it, if you read
it, you're going to do a
reflow, and you could
potentially repaint.
Another one is
getClientBoundingRect on elements.
And you know what, it's kind
of iffy on some of these
whether it will cause
a reflow or not.
There are several good articles,
and I recommend
looking up reflow, HTML reflow,
to get a lot of
information about this.
But this is something that
you have to keep in mind.
This is the next stage
of app development.
And this type of performance is
what these apps are going
to be doing.
And you want your app to
be this performant.
Garbage collection is nasty.
JavaScript is a fun language.
And, obviously, the way the
memory layout works is very
fortunate in some ways, but
garbage collection is not one
of those ways.
So you want to try to minimize
garbage collection by
minimizing the pressure
buildup on memory.
One of the ways that we do that
in this Photos app is if
you consider it, you have your
main viewport, and you have
image elements for each
of the photos that the
user wants to see.
And we obviously have to
preload before and
after the view port.
And that could be 40,000
DOM nodes.
That's too many.
That's going to cause a lot of
garbage collection, a lot of
memory pressure that
you don't need.
Consider that you can compress
those nodes given like say a
square of 1,024 by 768
higher up that is not
visible in the viewport.
Get rid of all those nodes,
you can either store them
around somewhere, but at least
keep them out of the tree, and
replace them with one
div that's sized
the exact same size.
So that's like compressing
what you had before.
And that will keep the structure
of your document,
will not change the size
of the entire body.
So the user won't even
be aware that
you've taken nodes out.
A nifty little trick
you can do.
It's really important.
Leaks are bad.
Everybody knows that.
But you've got to pay
attention to it.
The profiler inside of
Chrome itself can
really help with this.
Let's take a look real quick.
Nope.
So profiles here allows you
to take a heap snapshot.
Obviously, the heap snapshot
for this is not going to be
entirely interesting.
But it does show you some of the
objects that are going on.
So we have like this slide
deck object, and
there are two of them.
So I may question if I only have
one set of slides, why do
I have two slide decks?
I don't know the
answer to that.
Could be a leak.
We found, in many instances of
just going through this, and
you can arrange things by, for
example, dominators, which are
saying this thing is huge.
Obviously, you want to go
through the native stuff at
the top that's not yours, but
get down to where you're
allocating stuff and say
this is too heavy.
This slide deck is too
heavy, for example.
And that's just one way to say I
need to go in here and start
looking for places where
I may be leaking.
I may not be freeing references,
removing
references, et cetera.
There are a lot of tools that
can help with this.
They're, in our experience,
not very great.
There's not a lot of tools right
now that have a very low
false positive rate.
But it can point you in
the right direction.
And it doesn't hurt to just run
it every once in awhile
and say these are the known
false positives.
These are the ones
we need to fix.
Listeners can get
very expensive.
We had an instance where you
would start the app with no
photos, and we had
40,000 listeners.
What are they listening to?
I mean, that doesn't
even make sense.
You need to make sure that
things are being detached
appropriately.
They stop listening.
They can be dangerous not just
in the memory footprint but
also in the processing
footprint.
If these listeners are being
fired on events, and they
don't need to be listening, then
they're going to do some
processing that is
unnecessary.
And that's going to hurt your
performance as well.
And we already talked about
profiling memory usage, so
we'll skip that.
So back to simplicity.
I truly think this is one of the
most difficult things that
you have to solve in an app, how
to get out of the way so
that the user can just see what
they want to see, do what
they want to do, minimize your
UI footprint, et cetera.
And the Chrome platform is
really starting to take over
this and give you APIs
that allow you to
get out of the way.
One of the big ones we
had was with sign-in.
Signing into an app really feels
like a web page that you
have to sign into.
Especially if you don't have
the ability to sign in once
and have that persistent across
multiple lifetimes,
multiple instances of the app,
it just doesn't feel native.
And we do, that's our goal
is to feel native.
Also, if you're signing in,
that's a step, that's a road
block to the user getting to
do what they want to do.
And so we really needed
a way around this.
And thankfully, the Chrome
platform has a way.
There is this thing called the
Identity API which allows you
to retrieve the OAuth2 token
of the user that's
currently signed in.
Now this app is right now
designed for ChromeOS.
But the Identity API works
on all platforms.
So if the user is signed into
the browser, you can get their
OAuth2 token for their
Google account.
For example, in this app, I
didn't have to sign in.
There is no sign in
button anywhere.
When you start the app, I don't
ask you to sign in, or
I'm not asked to sign in.
And that all comes from the
Identity API and the fact that
on ChromeOS, specifically,
you're always
signed into the browser.
So for an app on ChromeOS, you
shouldn't have to sign in if
you're using Google Accounts.
Now you may not be using Google
Accounts, and the
Identity API has a solution
for that.
It's called launch
WebAuth flow.
And so with that API, you can
pass in a third party URL in
point for OAuth2, and under
the hood, all of
the workings happen.
A pop-up is shown that allows
the user to login.
Now, obviously, that doesn't
solve the issue of getting out
of the way and not having
a dialogue.
But if you're not using Google
Accounts, which is a fair
point, you need a way to sign
in the user to your app.
And that token can be
persisted across
instances of the app.
So, for example, in this code
sample here, we are calling
getAuthToken, and we're
storing that token.
So for the lifetime of the app,
we don't have to keep
calling getAuthToken, we just
have the token around.
And we build our requests
with this token.
For example, the Photos
back end at Google.
We're going to do a request
to read all the
photos of the user.
And so what we've done is we
have the token stored.
We just keep using this same
token for all of our requests
in the app.
It's really easy to use.
So like I said, I had
a camera, and I had
an SD card in it.
And I plugged it in, and the
right thing just happened.
It's a Photos app.
I've installed this app.
I said I trust this app to
do what I need it to do,
including the fact that
it says it has
access to your media.
Currently, in the web today,
and in most native apps as
well, you have to select the
media specifically, say by the
file open dialog, which I
consider the worst piece of UI
in browser history.
It's awful.
But everybody has to
go through that.
The alternative is Flash, but
even then, you still have to
do file directory browsing,
et cetera.
We wanted to get rid of that.
The solution to this was the
Media Gallery API, which is
like the pinnacle
API in this app.
It's what makes this app pop.
It's what makes it real.
The Media Galleries API allows
the developer to have access
to media devices, so SD cards,
platform media, like my
pictures or the photos
on a Mac.
And it has a seamless access.
You don't have to ask the user
at the time of app running, at
the app running, only
at installation and
only that one time.
So in this app, we have UI that
shows up a notification
that says you just plugged
in a card, we're
going to start uploading.
And you have the ability to stop
the uploading, but that
action happens right away.
The user doesn't have to wait,
and the user doesn't have to
do the file open dialog,
which is just awful.
So here's a little code snapshot
of how to use this.
The API call is
getMediaFileSystems.
And if you're familiar with
it, it returns a DOM file
system, which has its own file
entries inside of that.
Its directory structure, you can
read through this with the
file system API.
So this is really neat.
We just have this one little
layer on top of the already
existing file system API that
restricts what is shown to the
app to just media locations.
For example, when I plugged in
the SD card, it knew that it
had a DCIM folder and said
we think this is a media.
It's a simple heuristic, but
it really solves 90% of the
use cases that we're
looking for.
If you plugged in an external
drive, and it had a DCIM
directory, we would say
that it probably has
photos on it as well.
And we would start
loading that.
So the first time I saw the
Pixel screen, it was detached
from the actual laptop.
It was not even put
together yet.
It was this little piece.
And he said, you have to
see this, one of the
developers of the Pixel.
And he showed it to me, and it
was just mind blowing, the
picture that he showed on it.
I'd never seen something
like this.
And then he started swiping it
and moving things around, the
touch on this one screen,
it was just amazing.
And so you have the ability when
writing apps not just for
this but say for tablets as
well, like high DPI tablets,
you obviously have MacBooks
that have Retina Display.
You want to make sure that
you're optimizing for these
form factors which are becoming
more and more prevalent.
And for the high resolution
display, it's not hard.
You just provide 2x assets,
high-resolution assets.
The API to do this
is in CSS itself.
It's called WebKit Media Set.
And you can specify
the multiplicative
factor, so 1x or 2x.
And you just pass in the right
resource through that.
One thing to keep in mind is
that you want to make sure to
set the background size of your
asset to the low res.
So we have this close icon,
and it's 32 pixels in the
low-res asset.
When we load the high-res asset,
we still want it to be
32 pixels on the screen.
So that doesn't blow up
un-proportionally.
We just have it more dense
inside of those 32 pixels.
You want to make sure you do
this especially if your user
is going to be on a
high-resolution display
because on most browsers and
definitely in Chrome, the
scaling algorithm for images to
scale up to high resolution
is optimized for speed,
not quality.
You'll get very blurry images,
and your users are going to
get a headache after a while.
It looks really bad.
We had a regression one time
where the high-resolution
assets were not being
loaded properly.
And every body was like, oh
my gosh, this is awful.
Something is clearly wrong
with this app.
And imagine if your user
saw that, they're
not expecting it.
They just know something
is wrong.
And to touch support.
This is a really fun
thing to touch.
And they always say, why would
you touch this laptop screen?
People don't want to reach over
their keyboard to do it.
But the more you use this, the
more you start touching
everything around you.
Like you reach over
everything.
I touch my work 32-inch monitor
expecting it to do something.
And it doesn't.
It's extremely frustrating.
More and more, displays are
going to be touch, whether
it's a hybrid, whether it can
be converted, et cetera.
Your app should really handle,
if not touch gestures
specifically like dragging and
touch start, touch end, to
consider what your user
actions should be.
For example, consider
the Photos view.
So we have this photo here.
I admit, I was in the wrong
when we were having this
discussion.
I felt that we should
have double-click to
activate these objects.
So if I wanted to go into the
single photo view for this
photo, I should have
double-click.
And that was me coming from
wanting to have a more native
experience.
And in native apps and in the
file system browsing around
things, you double-click to
activate for the most part.
And I thought that would be
a more native experience.
But then we had the issue of
well, what do you do when
you're tapping?
Do you double tap the screen?
No.
That doesn't work.
We could have it where you, with
a mouse or a track pad,
that you double-click, and
then with touch, you
single-click.
But then you have a very
confusing UX, your user
doesn't know what to do.
And then they're going to start
doing the wrong thing
the entire time.
They're going to start double
touching the screen.
So the key takeaway for this one
is just to consider that
tap support is very important.
Users are going to start using
tap and touch screens.
And you don't necessarily have
to have full touch support.
Just think about what your
UX is going to be.
I know a lot of you are
engineers, maybe some of you
are designers in UX.
But it's all our responsibility
to create the
best looking app.
So on to security, that
last principle.
This section, it can come
off a little dry.
It's kind of difficult to deal
with, but security is
extremely important
for the user.
And there are a lot of things in
the platform that at first
feel like you have to deal with,
but at the end, assuming
you start designing your app
the right way from the
beginning, you're
much better off.
Your user is much safer.
So content security policy is
this essentially white list,
black list that says your app
has access to these resources,
these remote URLs, these
domains, et cetera.
And by default, you really don't
have access to hardly
anything at all.
As you're adding a white list
for resources your app should
have access to, you consider
like your back end server, you
obviously need access to
that, and nothing else.
So if an attacker gets a hold
of your app, something gets
injected, and starts making
requests to some malicious
server, those requests are going
to be denied because
they're blocked by content
security policy.
The key thing here is to start
designing your app from the
very beginning with content
security policy in mind.
You can't load remote scripts.
You can't use eval.
And, for us, this was kind of
a problem because we were
getting JSON objects back from
the server, and so we had to
translate those into objects
using eval, and
we couldn't do that.
So what we ended up doing was
having a sandboxed iframe that
had the use of eval inside of
it, and we passed the JSON
objects into this iframe.
It would do the eval, get the
object back, and then post a
message back to the
app, this object.
So if something malicious goes
on, the eval is going wonky,
that sandbox iframe has no
permissions whatsoever.
All it can do is communicate
back and forth.
So you're pretty safe
as far as that goes.
Making requests.
So you can't say image
source equal remote.
You actually have to pull down
the bits for that image.
So all of these photos, we have
to pull them down from
the server.
XML HTTP requests is
the way we do this.
You just create your URL for
the request, send it off.
You get your response, you
should save it in your data
layer obviously.
And then once you get that,
the data gets bubbled up
through your UI.
And another tip as far as
thinking what you should do
from the beginning, designing
from the beginning, resource
compilation comes in very handy
with packaged apps.
We particularly use Closure, but
there are a lot of tools
that you can use to
do the same thing.
You're going to say,
essentially, in your main HTML
of the packaged app, script
equals some local file.
You could say a bunch of local
files, but it's a lot easier
to just have your code compiled,
have it minified, et
cetera, and say script equals
this local file.
So to wrap it up, we look back
at what our goals were, and I
think we really achieved
those goals.
We identified holes
in the platform,
APIs that were missing.
We added media gallery APIs.
We tested a lot of features
from Google+ Photos.
We got autocuration working
really well.
And we just pushed the platform
to its limits.
How far can you go with this?
How hard is it for developers
to use this?
I think the answer
is not very hard.
The biggest thing you have to
do is to understand your
constraints from the
very beginning.
Understand that you don't have
access to remote URLs.
Understand that if you want fast
scrolling, you need to
scroll your body.
And, obviously, the platform is
constantly changing, things
are being fixed.
I know I've reached out to the
GPU team a lot to say, this is
not easy enough.
We have to fix this.
And just imagine the evolution
that's happening right now.
You can see it at I/O. This
platform is just moving
forward at the speed of light,
the things that you're going
to be able to do.
It's getting a lot easier.
And it's getting a lot better.
So packaged apps, yeah, we
definitely want that.
And I think the way to think
about it in terms of how does
it relate to web apps is that
you could have the core of
your app have functionality
that is available
cross-platform, is not
necessarily specific to
Chrome, doesn't have these
extended APIs and permissions
that are requested.
And in doing that, you're going
to have a lot safer API.
For example, you've got to use
XML HTTP requests, you're
going to have content security
policy support, all of that
from the get-go.
And that's just your
core bundle.
Layered on top of this is all
the goodies that you get from
the platform.
You get the Identity
API, so use it.
If you have it, use it.
You get Media Galleries API.
Use it.
And if not, degrade
gracefully.
And this is how if you build
your app, whether it's for
Chrome packaged apps
specifically, or if you're
going to deploy it on the web
across multiple browsers, if
you do this, you can have one
product that can work on
multiple platforms.
And on some platforms, it just
has more functionality.
We've done that with Google+
Photos Chrome app.
And we think it's working
out really well.
So I actually think we don't
have time for questions.
We only have about
a minute left.
But I will be at the Office
Hours bar if you want to come
by and ask any questions
you have.
It's been a real pleasure.
Thank you very much
for attending.
And I hope to see
you guys soon.
[APPLAUSE]